[Music]
one comic is better than the other
people think it's them we're smoking and
joking and having a blast two Comics two
cigars two Comics two cigars
two Comics two cigars why did I already
did the promo shots
way to [ __ ] guzzle it should I start
again
I think these are great today what do we
got
do you remember the brand all of it uh
Romeo Julieta yeah Medias de Oro uh
reservas reserves that's what he made it
made it ever real he made uh certain to
let us know that they were that
as opposed to like typical ones
reserves does seem like reservist does
seem like you're way better off like
you're doing something right these are
going to be impossible to lighten this
heavy wind
uh hi I'm Ari shaffir this is Mike
Cannon this is two Comics two cigars how
are we going to do this I mean there's
literally zero chance we have to run off
camera and come back between the flame
the gusts of wind and also how
precarious this camera said oh yeah that
camera's constantly gonna look at that
one she's resting in the [ __ ] like a
cobra
um
it's kind of incredible though that we
do have technically a three camera
professional shoot in the middle of a
park and there's a security guard right
behind us looking to shut this down you
might run it off real fast yeah who
knows uh should we not look at him how
do you play this usually I usually don't
look at them until they uncomfortably
stand right okay you're obviously here
for me right yeah you don't drag him in
if they're just
glancing no and I feel like we're not
doing anything too obstructive should we
be ready with a uh Tony said we're okay
it's all right yeah like somebody tells
this game is permission kind of thing
yeah I'm terrified that my camera is
gonna smash
it's the I mean it's the most tenuous
[ __ ] of all the I'm uh I'll be at the
edge of my seat ready to ready to jump
and I mean it's shaking for sure yeah
yep and this [ __ ] security guard is
right there just this is just part of
the program guys when you do gorilla
production two Commons two zeros tell us
about this Romeo so we went to the Cigar
Lounge today
um the hill cigar in the most Italian
part of St Louis Missouri that's right
so much so that Fresh coat of paint of
the Italian flag was literally all over
the place not only on the what was it
the fire did Italy just get their
freedom or something do they just went
to the World Cup no as a matter of fact
they got bounced out of the World Cup it
does seem no reason for pride
yeah killing me just sitting there he's
just sitting there so we're just I think
he's calling it in no I mean if he
thinks he is he needs income or Backup
backup because it's two of us one of him
yeah but I feel like we look like pretty
docile whites yeah I mean I do want to
there's no there's no cigar things here
no all right let's talk about why we
chose a cigar okay we might not be able
to get the other oh gust of no wind go
ahead so this uh Romeo Julieta I did in
particular pick this one because my
father used to smoke this a lot every
time that I would go golfing with him uh
which is the only time we would spend
time together like when I reached out
and tried to like find a common interest
with him it'd be like it'll be golf
maybe yeah we can try it but I don't
think it'll work that's right and I even
had a bit about this on my on my hour
but uh he he once said this is like me
in eighth grade and I think he was like
trying to connect with me but he was he
said this tastes so good it's like [ __ ]
did it connect with you no no as a
matter of fact it really uh gave me an
uncomfortable image of my mother's
vagina
of her whiskey dipped [ __ ] do you think
that's what uh what's his name was doing
um yeah yeah yeah he was just aging them
it's like living in whiskey you ever do
that
uh and also I believe if I'm not
mistaken I do have a pretty good
encyclopedic memory and of Michael
Jordan trivia and information just
useless [ __ ] I'm pretty sure this is
his go-to championship cigar that he
would smoke
I don't know if it was the Reserva I
just remember the red Romeo e Julieta
band around the cigar maybe yeah I
wonder if those guys are like this is a
fine cigar or this is what I was able to
smoke when I was [ __ ] younger this is
like the best I could do I'm sure his
palette has changed since now he like I
mean he's probably like you know rubs
elbows with like the Saudi Prince and
[ __ ] like that like yeah yeah yeah well
this is made by a slave
dude this is never gonna work oh my God
oh my God this is never gonna work
dude zero chance
this guy doesn't have to kick us out he
just waited for mother nature hey
I mean zero chance that camera's down
oh my God what gale force wins are these
did we just did we get a tunnel I think
we did we're in between
should we go over that chair was that
was the first place that we passed by
well he said he might get kicked out
yeah okay let's just keep it going
I'll just keep it recording yeah all
right
just pick it up
oh my God that was [ __ ] nuts
[Music]
wow
this is [ __ ] crazy
I don't know what's happening right now
how do we try it here
yeah in there
yeah
all right that's fine let's go over
there
oh my gosh
what's this
Madness I don't know if this bench is
crooked or if my tripod is I'm gonna
assume the tripod is
oh God
I mean it might be tight in on us but
I do think it's moderately protected
from the
from the wind
I don't know though
oh God
way back there and zoom in
um
I think that's that's playing with wind
this is actually okay okay
yeah let me see
foreign
wobbling right oh no it is
yeah that's fine we'll just we'll keep
an eye on it you know
there's no there's no wobble free camera
Zone in St Louis
this [ __ ] thing God damn there's no
influence from here right but this also
this is uh
well that's not true Nikki Glazer but
maybe the most important influencer from
here
I do remember Jordan smoking well hold
up yeah get yours lit is yours lit not
mine is not mine is not close but I
remember and I'm not yeah
is this the first episode
oh God oh God
slow down wind
I am not your enemy
we should capture oh maybe that camera's
catching
all right
I'll say which camera was catching you
in the corner trying to light your cigar
hardest this is the craziest episode
but this is why this is why people turn
this is why people tune to Youtube
because they want to see this stuff no
production value okay give it a go we're
back
I mean we're gonna smoke as best we can
we don't have a full hour I do remember
Jordan smoking uh cigars as he was like
holding that Trophy and like still
wouldn't let it go yeah it was bad
fingers it just looked cool like I'm not
a cigar guy I'm still really not like I
I smoke them every once in a while when
it's like a social thing to do yeah but
when I watch that as a kid I remember my
goal was to do something great enough
and then have a cigar to smoke a cigar
champagne all over you yeah [ __ ]
let's [ __ ] smoker I've been pissed after
every one of like a special taping or
album or whatever there's been no
champagne death
yeah that should be
yeah
there is something about celebration of
having a fine cigar just having a nearby
you I think Joe list or as possible
Robert Kelly it was Robert Kelly brought
a box of our fathers or my fathers I
never remember that
um to Joe List's wedding and it was like
give him out and then somebody got upset
because it was like who smoke like
[ __ ] five puffs of this
but it's like ah it's at a wedding you
smoke as much you want the box is for
this it's not coming home yeah that's a
I mean from that then you didn't get it
for the right reasons yeah because
you're getting it to disperse you're not
necessarily giving it to you're like get
whatever you can out of this yeah yeah
this is this is the moment yeah this
this I'm the worst you did smoke cigars
with your dad or you just have a memory
of no I have a memory of thinking like
Michael Jordan turned me onto cigars my
father my father turned me off until my
until my adulthood like it just like he
made it look not that great because
Michael Jordan's is Peak Athletic figure
and it's like wow he gets away
four in a row just try to reach around
his stomach while hitting a three wood
from
the woods dude literally things are
falling apart in St Louis from this is
this is this tornado country
tornado episode number one two Comics
two cigars one tornado
I'm gonna go in the corner yeah go in
the corner do your best
it's very difficult
God damn okay this is definitely not
gonna be the best one let's all admit
that
um we did go we're in uh St Louis
Missouri we went to a place called uh
the hill Cigar Company
um this guy took some time with us which
was nice
I like it when a guy takes the time he's
like what are you looking for like
something light we went in oh he's got
to tell him what these are we went in
for this one we found yesterday in a
cigar lounge a private Cigar Lounge
I forgot what to talk about dude it's
okay the canoes we're doing the best we
can we're not gonna smoke this whole
thing
no I feel good about the fact that this
is even lit a little bit better yeah
so what was the plan today we went in to
try to recreate the cigar we found
yesterday
and I guess we should say what happened
yesterday what was that yeah well we we
went to the Ritz Carlton Ritz Carl which
we're not welcome at we're not those
people that became very clear by the
looks that we got just staring as you go
in it was like uh
I guess swingers when they go into the
party everything stops
yeah but even they were like dressed for
that event right they were just who are
the new people like we look like
[ __ ]
because you're wearing a flannel like we
all we look like like almost La Rich
yeah where they you know it's almost the
Mark Zuckerberg thing where you're
dressed down intentionally and people
have to guess what you do for a living
is a gap or Gap extreme yeah
so maybe we had a little bit of that
going for us but it didn't look like
yeah no I could tell when rich people
try to dress poor or their
interpretation of porn they can't fully
do it there's a Grime level that they
can't recreate
remembering um parasite when they're
like you smell like something it was
like it's a poor person's detergent
[Music]
and also I'll tell you who did it right
though and you have to kind of mix in
this lifestyle I guess is the Olsen
twins because they looked grimy because
they were doing coke and ripping right
all right right they stopped caring
about yeah they were just hanging with
Heath and just ripping rails God what it
must have been like to be in those days
level of like in and Hollywood or New
York
so I kind of was what do you mean
accidentally I I hung out with a girl
who used to actually hook up with Heath
Ledger and she was a wealthy not really
a socialite but like her her grandfather
signed one of the major American bands
and has so she has that type of money
wow I think so but let's see if it's
counted it is we're good
so for we you know I think I talked
about this on earpod or something but
for a little bit of time we were like
losing friends left and right they're
just dying oh and uh it's fun we used
her money
as like
medicated like we that's how we just
went out and we're living crazy and she
happily spent it and she'd take us to
like one Oak she'd take us to all those
[ __ ] places that I had no business
being in I mean you must get some joy
out of going for you it's normal stuff
and people like what like you have a fun
visit for [ __ ] Mongolia it's like a
squirrel I go somewhere there's more you
know it's like I don't care about this
but okay I can show you that's that's
exactly right but those places like I
never felt like I was cool being there I
always felt like I shouldn't be there
right right right there's a there's a
comedy gig in Hong Kong uh don't know if
it's still there one of the gigs was in
a hotel it was like a Ritz Carlton
documentary didn't they do didn't Segura
do a documentary no I don't think they
played they might have played there but
it was not that this was with Annie
curtain but
um you walk in it was the same thing as
yesterday where it's like we should not
be here yeah this is we're wrong we're
imposing on them and we're wrong yes
yeah and I mean yeah I was like is there
a comedy show here I was like oh I'm
wearing a t-shirt I feel bad
yeah when you dress like [ __ ] for an
event that you didn't realize was like
as upscale as it is yeah there's uh
I like it's hard I guess for them to
look at you like they they get mad but
it feels worse to be that person
overdressed I'm fine with I do it all
the time I lean into overdressed
don't like be shockingly overdressed
it's not working is it
you may have a chance you might have a
chance now's your chance
it's a video podcast so they're okay
with the silence
you're gonna get nauseous for sure it's
gonna smoke right into the top
I feel terrible
oh yeah
yeah I always get sick from lighting for
sure yeah like that's my moment where
I'm like I'm just all I'm doing is
breathing in
I don't really know how to do it and
then I'm just instantly nauseous before
it even starts I feel like I'm doing a
good job like I'm keeping it in my mouth
yeah
but I'm not like it's hitting the
outsides now oh nice you got it it'll
run
um what were we talking about oh being
out of place there so we ran into two
people from the show yeah
it just said Cigar Lounge yeah okay and
that's where we were going after the
show we wanted to check it out we don't
want to eat some unhealthy meals we went
there and uh we went the lady kind of
laughed at us she was like a little bit
yeah you need to be a a metallic or a
member of the cigar club I'm like oh
okay you don't just Waltz into the Ritz
Carlton I like our answer was like so
you can eat out here in the lobby do you
want a waiter like no we wanna would
would that then give us access to the
Cigar Lounge she's like no it's always a
good question though yeah because
otherwise she's presenting it yeah
yeah no we clearly want to smoke cigars
we're not just here for like crudite
yeah
yeah and then and it was she was like no
like what did I just tell you but it was
confusing In fairness she probably does
not come in contact with people of our
ilk yeah very often this reminds me of
uh renazisi and Simone and our agent
going to uh going to get a brunch in
Denver at a nice place that before we
all went skiing um and they looked them
up and down just like you know this try
you know trash but not like super trash
just have no sense of fashion and they
go
um it's 79 and they he goes they look at
each of them go per person
he was like do I not have that yeah that
will make you feel like you don't have
yeah like that hundred dollars they
don't want us here wow did they still
eat there I don't think they did no I
think they were chased out with the eyes
so anyway that's my favorite that's like
a dumb and dumber moment where you can
just like put double in their pocket and
be like I'll take seconds yeah
I'll take a second here's 170. yeah
um
anyway we're leaving we're like okay
yeah [ __ ] and we ran into two people
from the show who were staying there and
we're nice yeah uh-huh
um and we're like yeah we're trying to
we're not here turning into the Cigar
Bar times it oh you turn it off my wife
FaceTiming me [ __ ] her
um and they were like we'll walk in
there do you want us to walk in they
pretty much offered right well I I did
some some pretty slippery social
maneuvering myself if I yeah yeah you
played it right if I can give myself
credit how'd you say it because I was
like oh you know they would they said
You Gotta Be You gotta be a member or
you have to be staying here uh to go I
was like are you guys are you guys
staying here yeah that's right you did
it really well just kind of leading the
witness slightly so it's not I'm not
putting myself fully out there by being
like can you guys get us soon yeah are
you guys staying here and you're like
wait that was one of the recommendations
for getting in yeah one of the
requirements oh yeah
and they were nice and they they let us
in and then also hung out with us for a
little while for a little bit which was
cool yeah we watched the we watched the
warriors uh Nuggets game we marveled at
the Warriors ability to switch in in
Transitions and they're good so [ __ ]
fast and we hung out this really cool
old test Cigar Lounge oh we got to talk
about who was there
the the clientele oh yeah yeah it was
like a cardiac
surgery conference or something like
that yeah
I just saw the wind and I'm ready to I'm
ready to pounce
okay steady girl steady steady girl yeah
um
so that was a convention which I found
are fuck-a-thons
I stayed at the the uh crackers uh Hotel
you ever stay there no okay in
Indianapolis I haven't done that club
yet and I was talking about this chick
there all the time and it was like uh we
we're outside smoking she was smoking
we're both smoking but like uh there
were these two people out there smoking
we got to talking and they meet at like
TGI Friday's conventions and they have
like Liaisons no [ __ ] yeah like one
lives in Cincinnati and one lives in
like [ __ ] you know and they do the
managerial conferences and that's his
chance so they can like do some dumb
[ __ ] during the day free trip and then
they just get their [ __ ] on that's like
Peyton Manning having different chicks
in other cities and his wife just being
completely cool with it
you know isn't that I got hoes how do
you not if you're that type of traveling
successful person if he's like he
probably like sweetie I found one we can
trust in in [ __ ] uh Chicago
traveling failure
but yeah I mean you know what I mean
like that level of recognition and that
level of just like travel where it's
just like you know you know who you
signed up to be with yeah but the
cardiologist that's definitely they're
doing that on the DL but we were talking
about like this is their skank Fest this
is their skank Fest like they come
together they meet they rage there is
definitely a level in which most people
that kind of drop off probably head back
to their homes I'm sure there's some
people there was one Asian guy who
seemed kind of uptight he was like
almost like he'd been invited like let
me check out what the social scene is
but he's like no no I'm here he's there
just for the lectures right right right
right right right
yeah the connections but we so while
we're we're Milling about we're like
people watching everybody has the same
uniform on they're all wearing the
blazer with the white button up hide so
it's like it's a visual corporate
dominance it's almost this like you guys
ready to rage
yeah
let's do it yeah two buttons down and
they're ready for Coke God damn and
that's what it that's what it felt like
where at some point maybe that's why
they don't have a bathroom in there
because it became too much fuck-a-thon
they like concrete the Coke and the
[ __ ] yeah they probably had to cover it
there should be a bathroom in there yeah
however big one if you can only get in
with your ID card you had to pee and
you're like I can't because I can't get
back in if you did have your hotel card
it's not that big of a deal to go out to
go the bathroom no really it was just
restrictive for us yeah and but it's
still like a walk like we still don't
when we went to piss after we still had
to like walk around it's like hey I'm
missing like yeah three or four minutes
with it yeah it's a piss and the game
and the game that's right it's kind of
it's interrupting the entire flow of the
evening and as an upper scale
establishment you'd assume they'd yeah
that is one note for a cigar lounge at
the Ritz Carlton where we're not allowed
in when on uh welcome guests are in
there the the the proximity of the
bathroom is restrictive to our
experience that's right yeah we need one
so we don't have to use somebody else's
card to get back yeah yeah
all these good notes uh we did see some
skanks there oh it was nice and wherever
those models were I don't know who those
were I think they were called in Pros to
be honest like you know how during NBA
All-Star Weekend they'll have like the
influx of prostitutes
are like we want you in here make sure
these guys have a good time investors
yeah those girl I don't think they were
from here dude they were they weren't
part of the arch conference for sure not
they were so good like they were really
good looking do you think St Louis is
that like high level in terms of
prostitutes I think they all have those
in there but the fact that they were
there that night is like what's up yeah
that's no that's no uh coincidence yeah
two super hot chicks three super hot
chicks together yeah and with like
thousands and thousands of dollars worth
of work so they weren't they weren't
like natural beauties though too like
they're there to work yes yeah yeah that
was interesting
they were because they were just some
regular like some Arch some some
whatever Chiropractic conference chicks
who were like yeah I mean I'm still my
husband's not here right like let's go
for it yeah even if they weren't gonna
[ __ ] they were at least getting loose
that to me and you know I'm not much of
a prostitute guy but that to me is more
attractive than that like hardcore Tommy
Lee hot girl you know what I mean like
almost like the whitest lipstick yeah
the standard stripper yeah yeah yeah
like I I mean I'm certainly attracted to
that they're I agree with that but
hotter is like the almost the uptight
businesswoman that looks like she's like
dying for you to fist her yeah yeah like
my husband never gave me this yeah yes
that would make you hard open mouth I've
seen it in a film once
look at that guy is that graduation
there are so many events is that a
graduation you think all right look at
the kid it's a prom dude it's problem
yeah yeah yeah but it's not even May
it's April yeah junior is it maybe just
a formal
they're going somewhere yeah maybe it's
a college thing because this is a huge
college campus we decided we we saw yeah
what was that University of Washington
St Louis yeah big campus Big Campus
shockingly for an out-of-state
School
right like Washington University of
Washington is Washington State oh so for
them to have a Saint Louis okay but let
me just offer a different explanation
one of our founders of this country was
named Washington yeah so it might be
named after him so maybe Washington
University is Washington State and then
this one University of Washington is
named after George yeah
I wonder if neither of us are right or
if one of us are right or both
I think it's probably a satellite campus
I didn't see whether or not their
University of Washington St Louis yeah
but you can't be out yeah weird out of
state in state school yeah so do you get
like cheap tuition if you're from
Washington State and it's a great
question St Louis maybe if it's like
this is where the specified like majors
are where you have to come here if you
want to be a veterinarian or whatever
yeah maybe dude are you gonna send your
kid to college based on how much it
costs now I know it's a while off it's
not even like it's not even so much on
the on the on how much it costs it's on
the uselessness of it because it's not a
waste of years it's a waste of years and
maybe not socially like maybe socially
it kind of gets them into the flow of
things I would give you that for sure
yeah that's certainly not worth seventy
thousand dollars a year though right
right what's the price of all that that
you're almost better off getting them an
apartment in the city and say get a job
doing some low level thing that you want
to do I remember dating a girl she was
like 22 but she had she had started are
working at 18 and she was far more
worldly than than like a fresh out of
college right more experience but also
she's like I have four years of
experience yeah like she's more hirable
than like uneducated or a diplomad
an inexperienced person College a
college degree that truly means not like
you just have to lie I lied just so you
have it I have I I thought I graduated
from Geneseo yeah I found out a year
later when they sent me some sort of
letter that I didn't so I was on the
Walking graduation really and then a
year later they told me that I didn't
graduate because I was missing three
credits and it was public speaking
so you got it which is insane you've got
it's like the whole I have it you should
you should be able to write like having
a stand-up comedian for a year or two
like I did I offered to do a thesis on
stand-up comedy and pay for the credits
and pay and they told me [ __ ] you like
yeah you got to come back or transfer or
whatever and I was like oh I'll never
donate a dollar three credits short yeah
you're gonna get it when you're like 65
and you're gonna buy your kids
graduate no I want to be like Bill Cosby
and just get a [ __ ] doctorate okay no
because then they can strip you of it if
you raped a dozen or more women
um you're gonna go [ __ ] this is like you
know I gotta meet you want to count it's
like uh you don't want to be in that
place then you wake up you're like I
wasted one
um but yeah I mean so that's
I just I just don't know but also you
have to send them to grad so graduate
school is the new four-year College
because it used to be you go to college
you get a new job now it's like basic
you don't get [ __ ] that's that's like
going to high school you have to get a
like a some sort of specified degree
yeah a graduate degree to get any so why
not go straight to trade school or now
you have seven years of experience right
one year Gap year one year travel right
you know and then and then which tons of
social experience yeah and then your
worldly and then three years of work and
you're better off the thing that I so
what I have thought and what would have
maybe been a better path for me is my
the only good Academic Year is pretty
much of my life where the two years of
Community College I went to I like
focused I buckled down I had three nine
three little [ __ ] party for losers
exactly I played basketball too so I was
just like Super Hyper focused I wish
that I didn't do journalism or whatever
horse [ __ ] I was doing I wish I actually
actually consider doing comedy or
whatever back then and then just did
like a business degree on top of it yeah
get a base associate's degree in
business and then take that to then take
further courses or whatever drop a
business plan like that's what I would
like my son to do where it's like get
the base level of knowledge of business
and then take specialized courses
the University of Maryland or I need
like Junior business writing which is
like how to write a resume so like that
like that's came in handy
maybe one or overall like the great
class I didn't have that really yeah
what a great [ __ ] yeah I wanted to
follow up how to do a follow-up letter
after an interview yeah I took I did
take uh First Amendment law though which
has uh which has proven useful in comedy
really yeah free speech libel malice all
that stuff but uh that's funny I do that
I think that's like the next kind of
thing where you almost build your own
degree or build your own education where
it's like get your Associates for cheap
go to a community college or something
like that Rocklin Community had like an
honors program where people went to
[ __ ] Harvard from really legitimately
if you take it seriously you can
somebody's getting killed who's getting
murdered or they're just having fun
playing yeah one of those two I would
say whoever's doing that needs to learn
like different be more clear yeah it's
not quite bloody enough to be bloody
yeah it's not but it's close it's not
fun yeah it's closer to bloody I'd say
than friendly
oh and that lady is getting stabbed
maybe it was her
she was the one yeah oh well but um
yeah I would say like nah we're done
with this
you wouldn't send your kid to college I
don't think so no I think it's a waste I
mean not a waste there is some benefit
you get out of it but like not worth all
that and what you're giving up no I
don't think it's
but then as it comes I mean like three
years out of college you're not saying
where you graduate anymore it's just
like it depends where you go though
that's the thing as a comedian we can
understand the importance of the Netflix
stamp or HBO stamp right to Harvard to
prospective suitors again like if you
have that stamp but if you say I went to
University of Maryland
it's like it's public library but it's
like nobody's like unless they're they
also went to Maryland then it's like yes
yeah then there's like there's a
camaraderie I'll tell you what they were
talking about like the Gap year and and
the the hole in your resume and how
people should just like lean into it
it's like yeah I spent a month in Laos
and then I went to like I rode a train
from you know Tibet to wherever like
what instead of going like yeah I went
to school again for a year right it's
like way cooler to say that yeah and
also it gives you an interesting
perspective like dude I as a comedian
early comedian I tried to get as many
office jobs with zero responsibility as
I could so even when I was offered like
hey do you want to do more I'd be like
no I'm doing this to do comedy yeah I
don't want to move up in this place but
even at the end they were bringing me
into like pitch meetings for advertising
and marketing plans trying to punch it
up and make it funny because they knew I
did comedy so they they're more worth it
that additional perspective they were
like come in you have more to offer than
this dip [ __ ] that went to Brown yeah
you know I had a friend who worked at
the patent office very interesting job
showed us the pads all you got to do is
say if it fringes on another patent or
if it's original you don't have to say
if it's a good product or anything but
um
he said they kept trying to get hired by
law firms because they're like oh you
know that side of the patent office so
the patent law law firms are they're
like every year you work in the bad
office you're more like worth it to them
to have you to give you like you know a
giant salary to be like give us a
know-how yeah stand up yeah it's a great
know-how that's so cool if you want to
do a non-standing job that makes sense
though they should pay you more because
you're like I'm clearly giving up a
dream to be in this meeting right so
like I deserve more
but isn't that crazy is that the onus is
to go to school and everybody says go to
school get your education I think it's
an old standard I think so too because
it's funny that even with that with
other [ __ ] it's the experience mostly
that counts and everybody unless it's
like
coding or something a very specific
skill you can kind of pick it up on the
fly yeah exactly you learn on the go
yeah but it's like yeah people 10 years
out of college are way behind the people
just getting out of college for Tech
stuff yeah it's like you just got to
keep up yeah well that that's what's
like most of these kids that are just
self-learning all this [ __ ] are not only
surpassing people that are already
working in the professional world yeah
but they're developing past oh dude I
think when we were I was at Maryland we
had the guy in school with us the guy
who invented the Palm Pilot it was like
26 or something like that he's like yeah
I'll get an American degree it's like
yeah
it is funny though I just performed for
like a a group of 50 or 60 15 to 17 year
old kids from Ireland really it was like
a school trip and I came to New York
comedy I love those and I asked I was
like do any of you plan to come to the
states for college and they were like
are you [ __ ] kidding me it's been
that much they were like that's a joke
they're like you could get a way better
education for far less money over in
Ireland and then I'll work there and
then I'll probably get poached by one of
your companies anyway right yeah
honestly that's what you should do send
your kid to school in Ireland yeah where
it's like now you have life experience
being in a new place learning a new
culture
and you get a [ __ ] great education
for [ __ ] 800 bucks a year
oh you're out of state okay 950.
nyu's like 70 grand a year yeah I think
it's more than that more if you like
books in [ __ ] room and board yeah ugh
it uh I mean you get to [ __ ] though
great place to lose your virginity did
you do that college we'd lose your
virginity in NYU no I
so I when I went to I went to two years
junior college and then I was like
basically applying all these different
places most of which that would accept
me in basketball and I applied to Tufts
almost as like I have a really good hold
on yeah
the elephants
what's Tufts dumbos
oh maybe they're they're messed up I
don't know
I don't know I don't know if they even
have one they're just like Tufts
University top 50 in the world that's
their whole [ __ ] yeah and they were 60
at the time 60th in the world 60 000. oh
my God a year and they gave me 14 000
for academics and I was like super
excited because I had no idea how much
they they were saying 45 more yeah and I
was like oh I can't do that I'm still
I'm paying off [ __ ] SUNY still to
this day it's like yeah I mean you know
as long as it was it's not like it's
worth that much it's nothing in your
field except experience there is
something to be said for like I'm now
through like breaking down books I'm
able to critically and analyze the world
I you know the one thing that I got out
of it was I have one friend still okay
basically and I have friends is
something yeah I have a lot of friends I
only have one I have more friends for my
first two years and I also got um this
one class humanities out of it where I
had to read the Bible I read like
Dante's Inferno all these different
religious texts that we then abstractly
or metaphorically broke down as opposed
to like just what does this mean by word
definition and it was maybe one of the
most interesting two classes I've ever
taken and I do credit them with changing
my thinking a little wow yeah that's
cool yeah that part is real that part is
real of the the ability like I can think
differently now yeah
yeah now I'm a brainwashed liberal yeah
but also something to be like all the
people went to college and had a good
regular four-year college experience
four and a half five but like um
when people are like oh I didn't go to
college I don't have that experience
like yeah but you do have a different
experience you do have hanging out with
your work friends yeah yeah yeah you
know you have or going to Community
College like there's a different it
doesn't mean it's better or worse just
different yeah I have buddies that went
like straight to iron work and they now
they're making like 180 Grand a year
they're they're gonna so much debt and
you just keep paying off the principle I
mean the interest yeah it's crazy and
and all of them like they they were
[ __ ]
not dumb but certainly not they didn't
do well at school I paid me off like six
years ago and I'm successful yeah like
like I've been doing well yeah I don't
have a lot to go I have like I have one
big paycheck away wow from being able to
be like you forever you're gone yeah I'm
done
but man is it a frustrating thing to
just even have looming it sucks it's
like I'm I'm three years away from 40
and this is still in my life now I'm
gonna get my education yeah I like how
Ed O'Bannon was like was like um like
well they give me an education like no
they don't they're just writing us a
note right they're not we're not taking
Kinesiology classes and dumb [ __ ] PE
[ __ ] we're not actually getting a
[ __ ] we're not lawyers suddenly yeah
they're just writing us a [ __ ] and
they get them for free it's a receipt
yeah it's a receipt like hair hair it's
college educated but it's just fake it's
like he said it's like giving a
hamburger if you're a restaurant like it
cost you like 17 cents yeah the people
that's like people that were surprised
that Kyrie Irving was like a flat
earther
and they're like he went to Duke it's
like he went to Duke for 11. right right
right right right right and he probably
he wasn't in the research Department he
didn't go to a single [ __ ] class
exactly like that guy is not Duke
educated yeah it is nice for the people
who are like on the golf team like no no
I not going pro right I will use this
education you know for free with a
little bit of golf
yeah 100 but that's the one of those
things though we were talking about
where you use comedy to travel and
you're like wow look at this jokes got
me here it's like those guys golf just
got me a medical degree you know yeah
they just paid for myself Sean Bradley
yeah no Bill Bradley oh Sean Bradley
died yeah really being too tall
wow no Bill Bradley is what I was
thinking of the senator yes director
Senator yeah our Senator it's like you
were just a basketball player BYU also
or no I think he was yeah
Bradley a Mormon name
I don't know
um get crazy eyebrows though what do you
think of the cigar honest opinion oh by
the way we're under so before I even say
this so this is the first one of these
you do I I assume you're going to do
more with other friends definitely um
oh at some point it's probably nice to
say oh so you don't okay oh here's what
I can say we're not under contract with
any of these people and we're not gonna
get anything and there's no onus to say
anything nicer or mean right anything
about them honest opinion because it's
just for fun yeah what do you think of
the cigar this is gonna sound weird to
say yeah this tastes like my Dad wow
look it really does interesting I am uh
I am in familiarity
do you know what I mean yeah the smell
can bring you back yeah
yeah that's what that's the sensation
I'm feeling right now like I am very
much in conversation with you and also
kind of on Blue Hill Golf Course right
now in Orangeburg New York wow yeah
that's cool yeah it is cool I'd say
worth it yeah I went to get um Burmese
food with Bobby and um Bobby and uh and
Big Jay and I didn't think they'd say
yes but we're in Fort Wayne they said
it's the largest amount of people from
Myanmar outside of southeast Asia no
[ __ ] City so I was like okay so they had
a few we went surprised that they're
don't they're not adventurous eaters but
they went and they enjoyed it enough but
here oh here's my point just that taste
that first taste I was instantly like
the the memories were coming back like
where I'd eaten this before yeah smellos
are for sure one well yeah oh it just
takes you to a place yeah yeah I've had
uh I've had tacos that have brought me
back to Tulum uh it's basically downtown
Brooklyn Mexico yeah but but they do
have some of the [ __ ] best tacos I've
ever had in my entire life and every
once in a while you'll get hit with
something there's a place that's in um
in the Chelsea Market where they make
their own tortilla and everything is
very like an intent like that and it
tastes like that yeah that's interesting
and you're almost like [ __ ] I'm in a
rope swing right now dude this is
[ __ ] new this is gnarly yeah it gives
you back memories that weren't even
there like so hidden
like you can see a crack of a sidewalk
almost like it's like a sort of picture
yeah yeah so this takes you back to your
dad on the golf course yeah and it's
cool and it's funny that like you know I
have I've spent long long years on
podcasts uh talking [ __ ] about my dad
and just our relationship in general and
now I'm attempting to move past it and
I'm I feel like I'm emotionally at the
best place that I've been yeah about it
and this is not flooding me with
negative he's still alive yeah you still
talk to him uh we now talk so like we
didn't talk for a long time we had a
really really destructive violent
relationship for a long time so crazy
yeah and now it's just kind of like all
right
it's whatever I've I'm I'm just trying
my best so nuts well because my you know
what did it and this might not interest
you because it does involve children but
my son sometimes has my dad's face
like oh so basically think of him again
and it no it makes me think of his
childhood and it brings me back to the
fact that he was once just a kid an
empty slate and he was impacted Enough
by his abuses to become what we became
right right you know what I mean so yeah
when you see that it's like oh you're
just a product and some [ __ ] that
happened yeah yeah and it really made me
like empathize with him in a deep level
where I don't excuse a lot of the [ __ ]
that he's done because it's still his
decision but it does make me feel for
him I get that it's like when people
like [ __ ] on somebody on Twitter some
comedian and it's like what the [ __ ] but
you're also like oh you're you're an
addict to that thing or or you're going
through something of your own that's why
you're lashing out I it is bothersome
that is lashing out at me or that he was
a bad dad to you yeah but if he was a
doubted someone else you could be like I
see why you're like that your dad hit
you 100 but it's like his dad put a
pistol in his mouth right in front of
him wow that's hot didn't pull the
trigger but blew it blew it long and
hard wow really no no no yeah all eight
kids were there and my grandmother and I
think he did some
some months in the funny hospital and
then I spent quite a bit of your dad no
my grandpa right so then it's like you
can forgive him a little yeah or
understand it yeah
it's not it's not even about forgiveness
it has nothing to do with forgiveness it
has everything to do with understanding
and just kind of like now I'm I'm I'm a
man like for the first time in my life I
feel like a man because I'm very much
responsible for the life of a human
being yeah my wife could do without me
before we before we had a kid if I died
she'd be fine okay yeah
she'd be hurt but she'd be fine my kid
would be it would be really [ __ ] like
he you know it'd be it'd be a tough blow
for him so that that change and that
responsibility has made me throw away
the little boy that was upset with my
dad right because it's not even that you
know it's like yeah understanding is
good but like if I look at like even
Chris Rockwell Smith and it's like 100
you know we're I'll be comics on the
same side of this pretty much yeah
um but like
I can also not excuse but understand
Will Smith oh this chick is [ __ ] yeah
man making your life hard yeah like
don't still don't do it but I can't be
like wait what was that it's like no I
understand what it was yeah he
overreacted but I get where where it's
coming from do you know what it made me
not enough to forgive him but like no
yeah you know what it made me understand
about Will Smith is that there or or
about anybody in general in Fame is that
there is no amount of money that makes
you stop reading comments
because that [ __ ] read the
comments that's what that was that was
two years of hearing [ __ ] jokes of
hearing she [ __ ] she wishes you were
Tupac she [ __ ] that that your your
son's friend like like what the hell
this you know all that [ __ ] and that was
what was swirling in his brain very
clearly in that moment where he just
lashed out to an innocuous joke
foreign
yeah she just [ __ ] ran over you yeah
and who and you know me personally who
also reads comments that are very
hurtful I get it right it's like I get
it you can still right you can be like I
don't forgive you I don't I don't yeah
I've never Justified
I get why you'd want to yeah
yeah understanding will help the world
yeah I think so because it the the
Forgiveness thing is [ __ ] because I
don't think people really do there's
always a part of you that hangs on to it
even if you're like I forgive you you're
like you didn't forget though no no it
really is like oh yeah I don't think
about that right yeah or like if they
say like I forgave you instantly you
really do forget about it yeah if I was
supposed to meet you there and like and
you went to the club without me yeah I'm
like hey man I waited for you for like
20 minutes like I'm really sorry a month
later I'm not thinking about it though I
really did forgive you thank you for
saying you're sorry and it's just done
yeah yeah but those big things like
indelible scars those are not yeah I've
moved on past it yeah I'll have in my
life but that was wrong he wronged me
yeah no similar to loss it's like you
know you hear people talking about their
parents passing away or anything like
that it's like you're not no you're not
there's no way to be that's just that's
that's Consciousness that's you man I
would choose to have them there forever
the best
I gotta get maybe some of these
yeah
um here's another thing we do because I
think we have to wrap it up soon yeah
because we're gonna shower right yes so
we gotta we got about half an hour
okay
this is Bobby's idea would you buy now
that you've smoked these would you buy
one of them
five of them or a whole box or or not
what would you rate it a buy box buy
five I said three because like one for
you one for a friend and then one to
have on your own but he likes five
or one they'd be like if I saw it again
I'd buy it again that's what one means
um I would definitely buy one those
those ones I showed you the um
uh the one I said one cigar of the Year
whatever that one it was like I
instantly bought five because I'm not
really going to give two of these to
Bobby I'm gonna smoke one with Bobby and
I want one for myself
that's not enough to get a whole box
yeah yeah I don't wanna like I don't
think so I wouldn't I don't know if
anybody besides me would happen yes the
shirt that's your experience yeah
doesn't mean no no you're not judging to
anybody else just yourself yeah just for
myself so if this is one of those where
like this will take me back to my
childhood yeah I'll get a pack I'd buy
one I think I'd buy one
because I also don't know if this is
like a cigar if you handed it to
somebody they'd be like wow you know
right right thank you so that means if
you saw it again you're like okay yeah
these will be in cigar stores this is
not a rare one right no no and how much
how much what was it it was nine dollars
nine dollars yeah that's crazy cheap
it's a nine dollar good time I almost
never smoke a cigar under 10. no I'm
like this is gonna be bad this is not a
nine dollar price cigar taste no and
sing it well think about it it's like it
is like it's less than a movie
if you chill and we're doing a podcast
and stuff like that it kind of is just
like watching a movie also you can do a
thing where you could have it like put
it out unless you're watching a whole
game a two-hour game at some point
you're just putting it up you're letting
it go out and then you're gonna re-light
it yeah
there is part of me though as somebody
who no longer drinks that would love a
whiskey with this yeah like love that
would be you ever do the dip back in the
whiskey no but that sounds good yeah
then you get a little whiskey taste just
right at the edge oh nice
um I would give it
I would not buy five of these I'm for
sure not buy a pack I would buy one
again yeah if I saw it I was looking for
a cigar like Village cigars where they
don't have a giant selection but you're
like looking for something you know yes
and I saw this like oh we can get this
this will be good yeah right yeah I buy
one
I want out of store I am a cigar sucker
though in the sense that like if it's
well packaged like the one that we will
always wanted just like wine and and if
it's expensive yeah I immediately assume
it's the best okay so yeah yeah exactly
like
I used to have a joke about it where I
was like Rogan had this Theory which I
don't mind it that he'll just buy the
most expensive of any like he was buying
a volcano yeah and this is when he had
news radio money or right early Fear
Factor maybe so it wasn't like he was
definitely Rich sure
um but not not Sultan rich but he goes
just buy the most expensive volcano
uh-huh well you know bong whatever he's
like it's gonna be the best one right
like well what feature because just
don't even waste time just the most
expensive one get it if you have enough
money then just do that 250 instead of
one night just whatever wow and I go
when I tour Australia I'm like with that
in mind the cocaine here must be the
best in the world and not this shitty
Supercut crap you guys have
it's real it's like a hundred a grams
it's so bad too they don't ever so when
they when they travel they go nuts on
coke look it's pure Coke which is like
not pure oh it's stepped on fentanyl
laced
so
um no they're not fentanyl though they
just have like baby powder well that's
nice
um
oh tell them about the cigar we saw that
we were thinking of going to go oh yeah
let me let me get the name of it because
it is a certain name so we saw this at
the cigar bus we ended up smoking a um
uh a short story uh Arturo Fuente short
story yes yeah and that was good for 13
we saw this place for nine
um and we almost smoked the leaf by Osco
Oscar Toro curl Hall and now it's a Toro
it's a Toro I Guess the Brands not the
brands but it's I think it's Oscar the
leaf by Oscar that's what that's what
all those things style of cigar oh maybe
it is yeah I don't know I don't know
those either
um and we were gonna get that it's 18 at
this place yeah how much would we find
it for we found it for 12. 12. and now
so okay just so you guys know and it's
Cigar Lounge instead of a store the Ritz
Carlton Cigar Lounge is expensive yes I
assume most of the people there probably
had their own those are those boxes yeah
those are cool I like and not even not
even just the lockers or anything like
that like I bet people brought their own
[ __ ] that makes sense and then they get
the drinks and the drinks are expensive
most of them yeah not the one I went to
today yeah but that that that almost
sold me because again okay I'm a sucker
for packaging weird rap yeah and we're
like is this cigar looks like we're
Splinter apart yeah yeah it looked like
you just smoked the whole thing yeah and
the guy's like that's the wrapper you
take that off
but then what did this guy say whatever
is I forgot his name he told me so this
guy the guy last night almost
romanticized it made it sound kind of
cool yeah so we're like maybe we should
get those and then we set it to the
gentleman at the at the cigar bar or
cigar shop today who was smoking a cigar
probably his third of the day as he said
or his third of the shift uh and he is
not in the shape to be smoking that many
cigars I mean that guy is that guy's
going down quick I said right to his
face like I can't smoke this much we
want to lose you I didn't know how that
would go
and then uh and but he made it he was
like oh yeah that's like just packaging
it's like a little gimmick and the way
he flippantly said gimmick made me feel
like it's gonna be [ __ ] fool yeah
yeah we're like oh no yeah I knew that
yeah of course I was such a sucker for
falling for it it's a great gimmick it
makes it seem more artisanal like some
guy did it with his feet on the beach or
something like that like it's just like
yeah insane and uh and yeah the guy
completely like switched me off of it
just with that little flipping like not
from you know to that guy's credit he
was not steering us to the most
expensive ones no not at all he steered
us to a nine dollar cigar and he wasn't
really what do you say for the price
point because he goes you can get a
better cigar but for this it's way above
this level and I would agree with him
yeah I would agree also and he but
that's right that's what you get when
you don't work on commission either it's
like if you work there and you're making
a decent salary then that guy is not
pushed to sell you [ __ ] it's not
getting tips yeah it's it's like he's
not trying to you know the Cod isn't
about to turn so he's not pushing the
special on you you know what I mean like
he's he's just There For the Love of the
Game and he was just providing us with
information which you know that uh
that's underrated
I agree good job I think he nailed his
job at that moment yeah he really Rose
to the occasion yeah
he gave us real advice I love it yeah
yeah that guy I think that guy's the
best part of the cigar and overall and
he recognized you as we were walking out
so it was the perfect bit of notoriety
you had already been Pleasant to him the
whole time being very friendly on a
non-understanding of him recognizing me
and then it came out I was like sweet I
already laid it down Ari's a cool dude
yeah cool cool guy yeah man that's the
thing is like you've learned from the
one person that like meets somebody once
on a bad day and then it becomes a story
is like I'm in the middle of selling
divorce papers I'm sorry I didn't have
time for it [ __ ] he was so rude they
don't consider themselves but I'm
running to [ __ ] that's the problem with
right being a celebrity is like every
you can't ever go excuse me you can't
buy anything they know who you are
they're like that guy was rude yeah I
want one of those cars so bad the new
Bronco I mean I would take an old one
over that but I like the new ones that's
cool yeah nice little uh a half half um
convertible yeah yeah almost like a Jeep
too but it doesn't have much of those
dirty I would assume they start at like
40. I would have to have that not in the
city it's a [ __ ] car for the city
that's a pay more for parking car but
Beach car or if you live in The Burbs to
drive around go to the mountains yeah
that's a that's a nice car all right
Mike Gannon thanks what's your podcast
called again here's the scenario and
then uh By the time this comes out my
special might be out but uh May 18th on
my YouTube Mike Canada uh let's assume
it's out so on my channel comedy Mike
Cannon comedy on YouTube it's called
White Privilege homeless wait I'm Mike
Cannon no just Mike Cannon comedy on my
social media is I am Mike Gannon across
the board YouTube is Mike Cannon comedy
just look up Mike Cannon you're gonna
find me and uh yeah it's a white
privilege homeless and then I have a
crowd work special Village homeless yeah
then I have a crowd work special uh
coming out in July and I have Ari
shaffir Jew will be on any day if it's
not out already
that's my new special and double
negative on Netflix guys thank you very
much for tuning in this has been two
Comics two cigars Mike Cannon Ari
shaffir and the Romeo e Julieta that
means and Julieta reservaria nine
dollars good job and the guy gave us a
[ __ ] oh yeah it's the bottom of one
of these boxes that we didn't use really
we did not use it all I'll save it for
another time all right good job
let's call it sweet